Pewds about to hit 70 mil guys!!
*Thanos snaps his finger*
"T-Series hasbig gay" *wow i just heard that*
EPIC THANO DABS
Top 10 dance moves
70 MILLION
Whats good? T-Series, go home.
*Clap* Meme Review *Clap*
Its time for YouTube's favourite  show everybody. *Which is still under the entertainment category*
Meme Review.
That's right. Welcome!
I'm...
Who am I?
The Memester!
[The woman talking]  *IT'S SANS*
[sound simulating text in Undertale]
*Weird eyebrow and tongue movement*
*Clap* Meme Review *Clap* everybody.
The first meme, lets get- jump into it.
What meme am I gonna have to kill today?
Kowalski, analysis.
That's right. It's time boi.
*Evil Laugh (?)*
It's time to die.
You dumb meme!
Am I the only one that doesn't get this meme?
Am I just supposed to pretend that I think this is funny?
CUZ ITS NOT! I DECIDE!
it's damn time this meme dies.
I feel like this is one of those memes
where half the people who post this are like...
Like, Yeah, "I get the joke"
Well, you just add the "KOWALSKI, ANALYSIS," afterwards and then it's fUNNy
"Allow CALENDAR to access your calendar?"
*Another voice dimension* "Kowalski, analysis"
K, fine, fine
[reading the text]
"Kowalski, analysis"
I mean to be fair that makes no sense
[reading the text]
It's always good to combine a dying meme with an already dead meme
That's how you know that this meme was over before it even began
Everyone knows pee is stored in the brain (he's right)
Just like men's cum
[reading the title]
Huh weird flex but okay
[explosion noise]
[reading the text]
Kowalski
You goddamn right, how about that? Can we have a meme like that?
You goddamn right about that, son.
[Reading the text]
Holy shiker, time travel is real guys
This was a year ago!
I still don't get it
Kowalski
ANAL
[reading the text]
I mean analysis
Wait is she 14?
okay, but like if you didn't know she was 14
but like how were you supposed to know
guys, how the frick am I supposed to know it's a 14 year old
I would kick out of the window is 18 (?)
this is why Japanese isn't fair
"i'm a college student" WHAT IS THIS MEME?
WHAT IS THIS MEME?
See no know und- this is one of those memes that just- you put anything.
I'm tired of it
It's gonna be my pleasure to review this
[reading the text]
UGHHHHHH
This meme gets a
*clap clap*
3, okay? I don't want to see it ever  in my life again
*spits on meme*
I spit on it, spit on it twice
That's how you know it's cursed forever. Begone
Next *clap* meme *clap*
Looks like it's time for special news report with Poppy Harlow
Good evening, I'm Poppy Harlow and you're watching a special news segment of PewNews
SPECIAL
It would appear that none other than the Super Mario from "Super Mario 64" and other various Nintendo titles
Have. In fact. Died
Reports said Mario was texting and driving at the time of the incident
*Mario impression* "Mama mia I shouldn't have texted while driving
was his last dying words
oh my god Mario in text and drive I am shaking and crying right now
our thoughts go out to his family, his friends, and loved ones
*pop*
SPECIAL
guys I have something very serious to tell you, something that I have never told anyone in my 8 years career of Youtube
*burps*
in revolves a secret around T-Series... and here it goes
Bruh
BRUH
Oh my gosh, have you guys heard this meme?
this meme is crazy, honestly
The bruh meme is so- it's so good
I don't know if you guys have seen this like, vine thing but like, they have these things where
I've fallen
"I CAN'T GET UP!"
BRUH
bruh! bruh!
eheh
bruh
oh, oh, oh, oh... bruh
bruhahahaha
bruh bruh BRUH
[reading the text]
brUH
*clap* *clap*
this meme gets a 10 everybody
it's a fricken 10
the bruh meme is gonna just-
it's the meme of the year. It's the meme of the year. Meme of the year everybody
[reading the text]
i'm crying, i'm shaking and crying right now
Follow your dreams and anything can become true
*clap* *clap* next meme
Never say the N-word, take it from an amateur
Take it from a light hearted student
*loud voice over*
I'm gonna say the N-word
*loud voice 2*
That's racist you can't say the N-word!
*sound of glass breaking and car screeching*
*Skipper voice* Mrs.Obama i've done it, i've stopped racism
*Mrs.Obama voice?*Thank you Skipper, now i'm free to roam this earth
*President Trump voice?* Not if I have anything to say about it- and I do! I'm gonna say the N-word
*skipper voice* MRS.OBAMA GET DOWN!
*Bruh and explosion noise*
See what i'm talking about? I'm doing you a favor here
if you're ever in a situation, just say bruh
just. say. bruh.
I'm gonna say the N-word
That's racist!
*awful static bee buzzing noise while the other bee yells for help*
bruh
This meme gets a important status
*clap* *clap* next meme (thank god omg)
This is uh, this is it this meme
listen, I'm just a news reporter, you can't put me- I'm just reporting the news- memes.
okay, i'm not the one making them so you can't blame it on me if they're bad, alright?
I'm trying to think of an analogy of how I feel about this meme
it's like when an ugly girl gets a crush on you
it's like ugh I don't want that
but it's also like well it's the only female who has ever given me attention, you know what I mean?
That's how I feel about this meme
"weird flex but okay"
[reading the text]
now everyone has taken it upon themselves on the internet to literally type "weird flex but okay" *laugh track*
on literally anything
it's gone too far, i'm sick of it
[reading text]
This reminds me of that- my very first email was Flex89
Don't you dare say it
Don't you- *laugh track*
[reading text]
it's okay
I mean no
[reading text]
it's so bad
"weird flex but okay" aw, who would have though that would have happened
someone took the literal context of the meme. Never done-heard-seen that one before
[reading the text]
The woke level of the meme!
[you guessed it, reading the text]
it's not a weird flex and it's not okay!
Am I the first one to say this? It's not okay
Stop flexing and stop okaying
I'm sick of it
[reading text]
This is not a weird flex, but okay. Shut the hell up
Learn how to meme like a real memester and stop it
You're not funny, you're pathetic
kids are literally posting anything, every time I tweet these days "weird flex but okay"
just shut the hell up
"weird flex but okay"
and while we're talking about this image, okay
someone pointed out that I walk like a virgin, which I don't okay
I walk like an absolute chad
You look at this, we're gonna go through the whole thing alright?
Back slouched
Maybe a little bit, okay alright fine
hair seems to overreact to wind
do you see that pristine hair? This hair cut doesn't move for anything, alright?
so 1:1
Head craned forward
Well obviously because i'm- well whatever!
Just shut the hell up!
I'm not a virgin!
This stupid meme *clap* *clap* gets zero, okay?
stop weird flexing, everyone stop
If I see a single goddamn comment talking about "weird flexing but okay"
alright, i'll kill you. That's right
This is a threat, what are you gonna do shut this video down for online harassment? Like I care
I've got Youtube's number on dial
I'll call them up right now. Hey Susan-
*explosion*
*clap* *clap* meme review everybody
Youtube's. Favorite. Show.
Do we have time for Bonus Meme?
Calling Sive
I regret to inform you all that we did not have time for Bonus Meme.
Also screw the Bruh meme do you know how hard it was to caption that
also PSA for anyone else that does captions, don't fill them with bullshit. Don't make it a comment section
people actually use these to read and understand. Thanks.
lol k bruh